[Música]
queridos amigos primera cuestión puede
un país pobre aspirar a convertirse en
un país de ingresos altos en pocos años
segunda cuestión cuánto tiempo se
necesita y tercera cómo hacerlo
amigos de visual político os doy mi
palabra de que estas son algunas de las
preguntas más habituales que no sabéis
hacer aquí en este canal ya hemos visto
en diferentes vídeos como muchos países
han logrado cambiar su suerte y
convertirse en auténticas locomotoras
pues bien en este vídeo vamos a ver un
caso muy particular sabíais que polonia
se está convirtiendo en una especie de
nueva alemania atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os hago una pregunta y como siempre no
vale buscarla en google cuál pensáis que
es la ciudad con más habitantes de
origen polaco varsovia tal vez cracovia
error con más de dos millones de
personas es chicago si tal cual como lo
escucháis
amigos los polacos no lo han tenido nada
pero que nada fácil durante la segunda
guerra mundial polonia fue el país que
más sufrió las consecuencias ni más ni
menos que 1 de cada 5 polacos casi 6
millones de personas que se dice pronto
perdieron la vida y tras este desastre
44 años de gobiernos comunistas que
además de ejercer una enorme represión
política también dejaron como resultado
un país pobre en 1989 cuando todo este
sistema llegó a su fin la renta per
cápita en polonia era entre 3 y 5 veces
más pequeña que la de países
desarrollados como italia francia o
reino unido sin embargo he esperado un
momento porque hoy las cosas han
cambiado
[Música]
desde que polonia un país que está
situado a medio camino entre parís y
moscú y que tiene casi 40 millones de
habitantes completó el cambio de modelo
es decir dejó atrás toda revolución
socialista su economía ha tenido un
crecimiento real medio de algo más del
4% anual
un momento un 4% anual seguro que estás
pensando que no parece mucho verdad que
si lo comparamos con las desorbitadas
tasas de crecimiento de muchos de los
tigres asiáticos casi parece una broma
verdad pues amigos hay dos detalles que
estamos pasando por alto
te prepares
el primero es que estamos hablando de
casi 25 años de crecimiento económico
ininterrumpido 25 años ni siquiera la
gran crisis de 2008 y 2009 afectó a este
país podríamos decir que polonia es algo
así como un gran buque de carga no es el
medio de transporte más rápido pero
cuando te quieres dar cuenta ha hecho un
porrón de millas
[Aplausos]
o dicho de otra forma los jóvenes
polacos no saben ni tienen ni idea de
qué diantres es una crisis
[Música]
el segundo detalle amigos también muy
importante es que a diferencia de lo
ocurrido con los tigres asiáticos
polonia ha registrado todo este enorme
crecimiento siendo una democracia
consolidada así que amigos ese mito de
que los países pobres necesitan una mano
dura para despegar pues como que no es
cierto
el caso es que gracias a todo esto a los
25 mejores años de la historia polaca
este país ha pasado de tener unos
sueldos medios ojos de entre 10 y 15
dólares al mes a tener una renta per
cápita que teniendo en cuenta la
diferencia de precios en cada país será
en 2018 superior a la de grecia portugal
y todos los países latinoamericanos de
hecho ya no se encuentra nada lejos de
españa o italia
pero llegados a este punto creo que hay
una pregunta que tenemos que responder
cómo se produjo todo este cambio pues
atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el fin de una era
durante 44 años desde 1945 hasta 1989
estuvo en marcha el estado socialista de
la república popular de polonia un país
satélite de la unión soviética por
cierto para que os hagáis una idea de lo
grande que era el control de moscú se
cuenta que cuando en 1950 el dirigente
polaco boleslav
beirut le enseñó al mismísimo josef
stalin un borrador de la futura
constitución polaca el entonces líder de
la unión soviética hizo decenas de
correcciones a mano que por supuesto
fueron tenidas muy en cuenta de todas
formas el régimen polaco fue por así
decirlo uno de los menos duros de toda
la órbita soviética
por ejemplo la mayor parte de la tierra
no fue colectivizada se permitió que la
iglesia católica funcionara con relativa
libertad y bueno la represión política
siendo muy alta no fue en cambio tan
intensa como en los otros países de la
zona
aún así claro como en todo buen país
socialista el estado lo controlaba
prácticamente todo y en 1989 su economía
estaba destrozada sin embargo gracias a
todos estos pequeños resquicios logró
surgir una oposición política de verdad
liderada entre otros por lech walesa el
dirigente del sindicato independiente
solidaridad el primer sindicato libre de
todos los países de europa del este
gracias a ello cuando el poder de la
unión soviética comenzó a venirse abajo
polonia se convirtió en el primer país
de europa del este- en poner en marcha
la transición política para abandonar
por completo el comunismo y así el 4 de
junio de 1989 se celebraban las primeras
elecciones relativamente libres el
proceso ya no tenía marcha atrás
[Música]
la terapia del golpe
apenas unos meses después de las
primeras elecciones en septiembre de
1989 el entonces ministro de finanzas-
leszek balcerowicz puso sobre la mesa un
plan completo para hacer volar por los
aires todo el entramado comunista y
sustituirlo por un modelo capitalista
tres meses después esta terapia del
shock o del golpe como ha sido conocida
se puso en marcha
polonia aplicó un programa liberal
llamado la terapia del golpe
la idea era o el paciente mejora o se
muere de un día para otro se liberalizó
todo en una economía que era muy rígida
y centralizada donde los precios y las
necesidades no tenían nada que ver con
la realidad nosotros la llamábamos la
economía lunar
todo era una ficción de repente todo
cambió
los precios fueron liberalizados los
controles suprimidos las personas
pudieron empezar a poner en marcha
negocios privados se frenó la impresión
de dinero la economía comenzó a abrirse
al mundo y se puso en marcha un plan
para privatizar las empresas públicas
vamos que en poco tiempo a polonia no la
iban a conocer ni los polacos además el
gobierno tenía una idea muy clara sobre
el futuro polonia tenía que alejarse
todo lo posible de rusia y estrechar
lazos con europa y eeuu
el resultado unos años después se
incorporó tanto a la unión europea como
la mismísima otan ahora bien qué modelo
pensáis que ha seguido desde entonces
este país
[Música]
y el cambio de rumbo os lo hemos contado
un montón de veces el mundo cada vez va
a mejor la pobreza se reduce y los
países son cada vez más ricos sin
embargo un momento porque a pesar de
ello pertenecer al club de los países
ricos sigue siendo una misión difícil
aún así todo apunta a que polonia lo
conseguirá dentro de muy poco tiempo y
es que amigos este país se está
transformando en la alemania de europa
del este
[Música]
fijaos polonia se ha convertido en toda
una potencia industrial que está
inundada de multinacionales y como en
alemania- sus pequeñas y medianas
empresas comienzan a cruzar la frontera
el resultado de todo esto desde 1989 su
comercio exterior se ha multiplicado
atentos por más de 25 y hoy las
exportaciones polacas suman ya cada año
casi 200 mil millones de dólares lo que
representa más del 40 por ciento del pib
del país una cifra altísimas
[Música]
de hecho el nivel de actividad es tal
que os puedo asegurar que cuando
conducimos por las autopistas polacas
sorprende mucho ver la cantidad de
camiones que hay
[Música]
pero ahora aseguro que la pregunta que
muchos os estáis haciendo es cómo
diantres lo está consiguiendo cuál es la
clave del éxito pues amigos tomar buena
nota
la receta polaca tiene cuatro
ingredientes principales
primero garantizar unas instituciones
que lograrán atraer mucha inversión
extranjera seguridad jurídica derecho a
la propiedad facilidad para montar
empresas y competencia por ejemplo se
han creado 14 zonas económicas
especiales donde las empresas que
invierten tienen muchas pero que muchas
ventajas
segundo controlar estrictamente las
cuentas públicas el gobierno de polonia
es uno de los más saneados de toda la
unión europea la deuda pública por
ejemplo apenas representa el 50 por
ciento del pib y muy importante también
desde 1989 han tenido claro que hay que
luchar contra inflación así que nada de
imprimir billetes para financiar al
gobierno vamos lo contrario que
argentina
tercero una educación de calidad si
habéis escuchado bien polonia ha
conseguido que su sistema educativo
funcione por cierto sin necesidad de
derrochar enormes cantidades de dinero
su tasa de universitarios es mayor que
la media de la unión europea nueve de
cada diez jóvenes polacos completan la
educación secundaria y según los
estudios internacionales como pisa el
sistema educativo polaco es uno de los
diez de los diez mejores de todo el
mundo y cuarto unos impuestos moderados
a que no te sorprenden por ejemplo el
impuesto para las empresas es del 19% y
del 15% para las más pequeñas y el
impuesto sobre lo que ganan las personas
sobre la renta es sencillo tiene sólo
dos tramos 18% para los primeros 24.000
dólares de ingresos y 32% para los
restantes
[Música]
y además como polonia es un país
bastante conservador las familias tienen
aún más ventajas de tal forma que si
tenemos en cuenta tanto el impuesto
personal como el pago para las pensiones
polonia es el cuarto país de la ocde
donde menos impuestos directos pagan las
familias atentos pues amigos con estos
cuatro ingredientes ha sido como polonia
está consiguiendo convertirse en la
alemania de europa del este una potencia
exportadora e industrial con un gobierno
saneado y un nivel de vida que crece sin
parar tal vez la mejor prueba de ello es
que en pocos años la gran potencia del
este ha pasado de ser un país de
emigrantes a un país de inmigrantes
[Música]
de país de emigrantes a país de
inmigrantes en los últimos años y algo
ha caracterizado a la economía polaca es
que hay trabajo el desempleo está
rozando el 6% y muchas empresas empiezan
a tener incluso problemas para encontrar
trabajadores al principio las compañías
extranjeras solo buscaban empleados con
mucha experiencia y títulos ahora acogen
a todos y les dan un mes de formación si
hace falta y claro si las empresas
necesitan muchos trabajadores y no los
encuentran los salarios suben el sueldo
bruto medio en el primer trimestre de
2018 es un 71 por ciento más alto que en
el mismo periodo del año 2017 el salario
bruto medio supera los 1.400 dólares
mensuales
amigos sabéis qué es lo que ha provocado
esta situación primero que muchos
jóvenes polacos que hasta hace poco se
marchaban en masa a países más ricos de
la unión europea ahora
deciden quedarse
y segundo en los últimos años se han
instalado en polonia más de 2 millones
de ucranianos sobre todo jóvenes que
buscan mejores oportunidades que en su
país de origen esto supone que en
polonia sean ya más los que llegan que
los que se marchan ahora bien como
siempre os decimos no todo es tan bonito
polonia se enfrenta a un problema de
envejecimiento bastante serio y el
partido ley y justicia un partido muy
nacionalista y conservador ha ganado
todas las últimas elecciones y tiene el
control del país algunas de sus
decisiones han provocado que la unión
europea amenace a polonia con sanciones
e incluso con suspender sus derechos
como miembros pero de todo esto
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo ahora
turno para ti visto lo visto crees que
polonia sería un buen ejemplo para cuba
o sería mejor el modelo chino déjanos tu
respuesta como siempre en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
es darle a like y compartirlo con tus
amigos
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]